82 unions and liberal groups
urged biden to go bigger on tax hikes
and hold the wealthy accountable
business insider story president joe
biden has unveiled his first part
of his first of his multi-trillion
dollar infrastructure proposal which
could end up being eight
which could end up being 3.5 trillion
dollars
in tax hikes 82 national organizations
led by americans for fair attack tax
fairness sent a letter to biden and vice
president harris commanding
the administration efforts to raise
taxes on the wealthiest americans and
encouraging the president go further
right so they're kind of pitching and
saying we gotta
this is not enough we got to go higher
so corporate taxes they're going to lift
it from 21
today to 28 that's what they're talking
about yep restored
state level taxes back to 2009 levels
meaning that still only the richest .59
of estates would get taxed return the
top
tax marginal rate on the highest incomes
to 39.6
from 37 today aoc came back
and said 2.25 is nothing we we need way
more than that
she pitches a 10 trillion plan well if
it's aoc i mean
if it's aoc she's a progressive expert
in everything she's an expert in climate
she's an expert in all things tax wise
you're a big fan of herself
you're a big fan of it i can tell
already she's so smart yeah yeah
progressive democrats unveiled the 10
trillion
version of the infrastructure climate
legislation people are asking what's
going to be in this money here right the
2.25 trillion dollars
where is this money going to be going to
uh
he released a sweeping plan to pump
money into transportation renewable
energy manufacturing efforts to combat
combat climate change funded by undoing
to cover the cost biden wants to raise
it we already talked about it here's the
numbers plan provides 620 billion
dollars for transportation
174 billion dollars for electrical
vehicles
180 billion dollars for r d research and
development
300 billion dollars to boost american
manufacturing 100 billion dollars for
workforce development programs including
training for those who have lost their
jobs as well as apprenticeship
initiatives
100 billion dollars to build a more
resilient electric grid 111 billion
dollars for clean water a hundred
billion dollars for broadband internet
213 for housing 137 for schools and
child care
400 billion dollars to take care of the
elderly and the disabled
is what they're saying and biden says
this is going to
boost the economy is what he feels about
it so before i get to the next article
i'm going to turn it over to you by uh
uh byron what are your thoughts about
this thus far
it's a that's a huge question because
you read a lot of stuff
one of the problems that we have is that
there are people that can remain in
power by creating class envy and a lot
of the tax increases don't really bring
in that much money
if you remember back in the 80s reagan
introduced a gentleman by the name of
art laffer remember artwork of course
he's from nashville tennessee can you
interview him i did
people don't understand the laffer curve
to this day most people especially young
people never heard of our laffer they
don't understand
they're missing out the guy's a genius
they don't understand that if you tax
people let's say at a hundred percent
okay you raise the taxes on the rich to
100 how much money you're going to get
from the rich
nothing they're not going to work if you
text them at zero percent you're also
going to get nothing so there is an
optimum number
where you get maximum revenue we talked
about this yesterday on the capital
gains thing
when obama was debating hillary
uh in the uh 2008 election for the
nomination to the democratic
to be the democratic nominee for
president i think it was charlie rose or
one of the big announce one of the big
uh mainstream guys
asked obama he said look mr mr uh mr
obama
um you said you're on record as uh
supporting and increasing the capital
gains tax but history shows each time
the capital gains tax was raised
the government received less money from
capital gains taxes
and each time the tax was lowered
percentage-wise
the government received more money from
capital gains taxes so knowing that
raising the taxes might likely bring in
less money for the government would you
still be for
raising the capital gains tax and
obama's answer was
shockingly and this is when he
completely lost me and a lot of other
people not that i was ever in his corner
but
he said yes i would for purposes of
fairness
i'm thinking to myself how stupid can
you be i mean
raising taxes if you're going to bring
in less money doesn't make any sense
we have corporate we had corporate taxes
before trump at 35
corporations in in other parts of the
world were down as low as i think nine
or 10 percent
and so what happened is lots of jobs
left those companies basically
domesticated themselves in other parts
of the world and we lost jobs obama said
nothing you can do about it
but there was something you could do
about it you could become competitive
tax wise
one could argue that the corporate tax
is kind of ridiculous to begin with
because it creates
double tax on the same dollar if you own
a c corporation which individuals can
own
most individuals don't set up their
companies as a c corporation for this
reason
but all large companies are
c-corporations they're taxed at whatever
the number is today it's
20 21 what is it 21 21 is right now you
used to be 35 in 2017 they were okay we
were the highest in the world
21 they want to raise it to 28. to
simplify the math let's just call it 20.
you make a dollar you pay 20 20 cents in
tax that leaves 80 cents
now how what does that mean wait we're
not gonna do it that way we're going to
do it slow pull up pull up
pull up microsoft word and here's how
we're going to do it everybody has to
see it and make the font big
it's very very important can you do word
or we don't have it
okay so make it make it bigger so we can
all see the size can you increase the
size of font click that
uh uh okay can we make it bigger or no
is there any way we can make that like
a 50 point font uh just write something
first and then see if we can make it
bigger
uh it's very very important for you to
see this by the way i
i have the whole transcript between
charlie rose's conversation
and and i have the whole thing in front
of him if you missed what
uh byron you just kind of went through
it quickly i think it's very important
for the audience to understand what this
really means
when you're explaining it and i want you
to explain again show it visually well
we can but but the bottom line to
remember before we go in and then we'll
talk about it at the end the bottom line
is that raising tax rates
does not necessarily bring in more money
doesn't necessarily raise revenues
so they say we got to raise taxes to pay
for that well you could raise tax rates
but you may collect less money
because if you collect 100 so so that's
critical
so so go to 50 points go to 50 points
okay put a million dollars there so say
a company does 1.25 million dollars just
put 1.25 million dollars
in profits 1.25 million dollars okay
so that's profits that a corporation
this is a small business this is not a
big business okay
the ceo takes a quarter million dollars
of salary so take quarter million
dollars a salary
just put 250 just put 250 yep 250 out
which he pays on that 250 say 40
taxes what's the number on the 250. 100.
uh so 40 taxes which is how much 100. so
put 100 000
below it put a hundred thousand dollars
right there okay
which means he nets right below 100
right nets
150 okay 150
which by the way just put k next to it
just put k next to it it's easier yeah
so would you net 150 now keep this in
mind that's if you live
in states that don't have state taxes so
we're just kind of putting it for if
you're in california add another 11
percent to it
which means you're only keeping 125 but
let's just stay with this right here
right
so what's left after 250 is taken out 1
million dollars so now go below and put
1 million dollars
put a bit of a space so it's separating
the two yeah go one more put one million
dollars
visually to see this that one million
dollars right now
you're paying 21 corporate taxes on
which put 21 below is you know 210
okay now let's take it to 28 which what
they want to do at 28
you would pay 280 000 so just write on
280 000
leaves you with what 720 okay
net 720
now if the ceo says you know what i'm
not going to leave the money here
because
i'm going to end up even eventually
paying what kind of taxes excess
accumulation excess accumulation taxes
so screw it let's just take this money
out
if you take that 720 out how much money
you pay on that 40
40 on 720 is what 288
so 40 on 720 is 288 put another 288 out
288 out of 720 is 432 so put 432 at the
bottom
432. this is all if you live in a
non-state
taxes this changes if you live in a
different state right
432 you net on a million dollars how
much taxes did you pay
56.8 percent in taxes you're getting
double tax tax
on tax on tax on tax not to mention that
when you go spend that money you're
going to pay sales
tax all kinds of all the property taxes
all the other taxes so when people say
you know
let me read this to what you said i
think it's very very important it's
exactly the transcript from april 17
2018
okay obama's sitting down
with uh uh uh charlie rhodes and here's
how the
gibson is who it was gibson okay
in last night's democratic presidential
debate this is when they say last night
april 16 2008 actually during the debate
he actually said that
was the conversation democratic
presidential debate between hillary
clinton barack obama moderator charlie
gibson and obama had the following
exchange courtesy of abc news videos
available i don't have it with you i
don't want to show because they'll take
it down
gibson all right you have however said
you would favor an increase in capital
gains tax as a matter of fact you said
on cnbc
and i quote i certainly would not go
above what existed under bill clinton
which was 28
it's now 15 that's almost a doubling
if you went for one to 28 but actually
bill clinton in 1997 signed legislation
that dropped the capital gains tax
to 20 obama says right gibson continues
and george bush has taken it down to 15
percent obama says
right then gibson says in each instance
when the rate dropped revenues from the
tax increased
the government took in more money when
capital gains was dropped
and in the 1980s when the tax was
increased to 28
revenues went down so why raise it all
especially given the fact that 100
million people in the country own stock
and would be affected obama well charlie
what i've said is that i would look at
raising the capital gains tax for
purposes of fairness
we saw an article today which showed
that the top 50 hedge fund managers
made 29 billion last year 29 billion for
50 individuals and part of that was
uh what has happened is that those who
are able to work the stock market and
amass huge huge fortunes on capital
gains are
paying a lower tax rate than the
secretaries that's not fair
and what i want is an oppressed is not
an oppressive taxation i want business
to thrive and i want people to be
rewarded for their success
but i also want to make sure that our
tax system is fair that we are able to
finance health care
et cetera so he goes into the whole
thing right but the point is this
history tells us
you raise capital gains the government
doesn't get more revenues well you can
people can control the timing of gains
so you don't have to pay capital gains
tax if you don't have capital gains
you can avoid selling stocks and people
contribute
discouraging me so like for example this
is going to pass in 2022
what do you think is going to happen in
2021 everyone's going to sell their
point
and then what do you think people do in
2022 2023 2024 until somebody
hold on to it just hold on to it so what
happens to commerce
the potential i don't know how it
affects commerce i can just say that the
bottom line is it's
it's about it's it's there should be an
argument for effectiveness
versus what feels good and it's about
making things sound fair and
and punishing people for achievement and
everything else to make everything equal
to equal equalized tax rates doesn't
make any sense it's all about generating
revenue
it's the same thing when you talk about
um
in the military i mean what you've got
now is you've got people running it that
think the most important thing is you
have to have diversity of
skin color okay diversity of thought
diversity of capability that's one thing
but
it's all about effectiveness if if that
brings if that makes us more effective
as a fighting force
that's great but if it doesn't let's not
do it it's not about
trying to make it look pretty it's all
about
making it be effective and i think the
tax system should be effective
we were going to talk about a state
they're talking about state taxes going
up estate taxes have never generated any
significant revenue and in fact even
corporate taxes
generate less than 10 percent of the
revenue from income or corporate taxes
it's not the main source of revenue
so why would you want to become
uncompetitive here make our tax rate
higher relative to other countries of
the world
and have companies decide hey where are
we going to set up shop we got a new
startup
should we incorporate in ireland or
should we incorporate here in the u.s
well in the us we're going to get
punished and tortured
with all kinds of regulations and osha
and unions and all this other
let's go someplace where they're more
friendly to business i see no reason why
we would not want to attract more jobs
but you've got our country was invented
by
geniuses and it is now run by idiots
by the way on top of that just check
this out here's the other part let's not
forget u.s companies operating abroad
who are paying
uh uh nothing abroad are currently
paying a ten and a half percent minimum
tax to the u.s right these are companies
that are operating abroad
the biden plan would raise that from 10
and a half to 21 doubling it doubling it
yes which
just so you know there's a part of that
i don't have a problem with because i
want the jobs to be more
here but still 10 and a half to 21 is
still a big number
on top of all the other proposals the
biden plan imposes a 15
tax on financial statement income of
companies if they don't otherwise pay
that much so this tax thing isn't but
again that's at the corporate level
that's at the corporate at the corporate
level then any any of the profits of
that company which go to the
shareholders which are everybody out
there we're all shareholders and
something
that's going every dollar that comes to
you has already been taxed and now
you're going to be taxed on it again
it's double taxation
i have no idea how that ever was
invented but it was
adam well i this is one of those topics
especially when it comes to corporate
tax that i
you got two ears for a reason i'm doing
a lot of learning i'm doing a lot of
listening and i appreciate some of your
perspective that we shared yesterday
on the whiteboard um so i'm learning now
you
the the part that pat that you said that
you agreed with
i'm gonna make a metaphor here but is it
the part that you said u.s companies
operating abroad
who are paying nothing abroad pay a 10
and a half minimum tax to the us
buying to raise that to ten and a half
ten and a half minimum to two twenty one
which is doubling is this kind of like
that tourist tax you talked about
with florida no there's a couple
podcasts this is what trump did
trump went to people businesses who had
their money offshore and said what
one time you bring your money you're
gonna pay minimal amount to bring your
money to u.s right one time
and if you bring your plants over you
trump was trying to bring plants to do
business in the us don't forget trump
was threatening businesses
that if you're doing business out of the
country he's he was planning on making
it very difficult for you because
he wanted everything to be what made in
usa
made in america that's what trump wanted
to do so i don't
i understand where he's going with this
part america first versus
america sure and i understand that part
i understand if you're doing a tax you
say bring your money here
bring your business here do business
america shouldn't you show your jobs
here
i would give an incentive rather than
you know
you know taking a route up bring it here
and i'm still going to tax you more if
you bring it here business is going to
say dude i'm not bringing it to u.s
because it seems like the more i bring
it to you i'm not going to bring it to
you so
when they say well i watched the msnbc i
was watching msnbc on the reaction to
this taxes
and it was like uh well you know what
all these guys do they all the
billionaires all they do is buy back
everything like everybody's put into the
same box as if
everybody does buybacks as if everybody
that's rich is a bad person as if
everybody that
makes money has offshore accounts as if
everybody that has a
business that's a billionaire pays
people seven bucks an hour it's as if
everybody
that has money is a bad person like the
way they are generalizing with everyone
being in a box
you know they're they don't understand
the math they're not good at math they
don't understand the math what about
you all the money explained this when
you explained this yesterday here's adam
adam's not a guy that's sitting on 50
000 in a bank adam's got money okay
adam's done well for himself in the last
you know 15 years he's made a name for
himself he's one of the best at what he
does he's not just a regular guy when
people think about that specific product
that he sells
they know this guy's name you even adam
was like
i don't think this is fair so think
about it even adam yesterday said
i don't think this is fair so you got a
corporate tax rate i'm going to pay 28
and then if i take the rest i'm going to
pay 40.
you're taxing me at 58 59 if you add
another 11
taxes that's 69 what the hell am i
working for
well you understand that in in the 1950s
you know what the
i was literally just going to go here i
mean you understand what they're talking
about double what it is now i mean
90 90 90 on anything over like 200 grand
you paid 90 percent boy
reagan was like look i i'm paying 90 if
i if i make another movie
plus this the california estate tax by
the time he was done he was paying 99
percent taxes he says why should i make
another movie well the
story with reagan was that he would only
make two movies a year
because he he would make a hundred grand
a movie and if you made anything over
two hundred thousand dollars you would
pay ninety something percent taxes so
he's like wow
that's an impediment to commerce you
don't wanna punish
achievement you don't wanna punish a a
business who's got a printing company
and he says should i buy another
printing press
and should i double and i should double
my jobs and everything else why why
would i bother doing so
if i take all the risk and if i win i
don't get to keep most of the money
we're already paying over 50 on all the
taxes i mean at what point
and i ask my lefty friends like what how
much is too much
what number is just too much and if you
talk to aoc
she'll say 90 percent that's what she
says
she's tax rate she thinks that people
forget in this country like taxes are
lower than it's ever been in
the history of america stop it buddy is
history top marginal tax rates no no no
it was 28 in 1988 okay okay i'm saying
relatively speaking whether you're
talking 20s and 30s now well yeah
you act as if it was 90 for like years
it was it was it was 90 for a long time
what's a long time
decade 15 years 90 percent was top line
longer than
what income longer than uh anything any
marginally the nth dollar over 200
and the dollar over 200 was that what 90
yes
maybe it was 400 it might have been 400
so how did rich people take their moneys
out what did they do well there was a
lot of deductions and things like that
but then they played obviously figured
out ways to not
show income there's no way in the world
i mean it's not like that strategy is
going to work check what i just sent you
we should pull this
up 90 for people about 200 for decades
yes what year was this and who was
president
uh well it was all through all through
the 50s everything all through the 50s
and part of the 40s for sure
i mean you know what was the common
sense behind this
um i don't think there was there's a
logic behind it well they had
the tax code is always there you go
check this out
ninety-one percent go down start out
started in the fifties okay no not
actually fifties if you're thirties
no thirties you got eighty percent okay
so you got eighty one
this is when the war was going on so it
started in world war ii so
63 it was at 91 so you're talking about
a 25 year
90 top line now what was top line tell
me what top line was
like the number that you had to make i
can tell you that that in 99 going up
they showed on the bottom what top line
was in go go put up 1990
1963 uh top marginal rate income see if
anything comes up go ahead you were
saying 19. in 1980 i believe it was 400
grand and you paid 70 percent in 1980 on
everything over 400 years so people for
this was my point pat plus your state
tax right now whether it's 21
or 28 or 30 or 30 40 even
people forget that it was as much as 70
80 90
for decades in this country which i
don't
i mean none of us were even freaking
alive then but how does that something
like that happen i think it's important
to understand our friend democrat
tax foundation click on that he cut it
democrat cut it john f kennedy he would
not be a democrat today
he'd be a moderate republican
sometimes the tax rate the rates of
amazon affiliates from 1950 to 2000 1950
top 191 percent richest expert claimed
roughly equivalent amounts of
entrepreneur income and claimed equal
amounts of wage income and entrepreneur
income in terms of business
passive okay got over the next 30 years
as high as tax persister percentage
entrepreneurial income claimed
by the rich dropped from roughly 35 1950
7.8 1981 the likely cause
was the gulf between the top individual
tax and corporate tax rate in the 1950s
the top tax rate on traditional c
corporations was 52
and some 39 percent lower 39 points
lower than top individual tax income
kennedy's tax on 1960 to lower the tap
it's a rate to 70 percent and a
corporate 40 of something so very
good for me to see the bottom right here
go ahead yeah right there keep going
i'm listening to you go ahead what's
really important is to understand that
no matter what the top
tax rate is this is a nominal number
okay it's just
there's a number there the way people
behave and what they actually pay
doesn't necessarily
match this so in years where it was 90
if you took a guy who made 10 million
dollars
so how much money did you pay in tax
last year he wasn't paying nine million
dollars in tax if he made 10 million
dollars he had all kinds of deductions
he could deduct his
yacht he could deduct this marginal tax
rate i'm just i'm just saying there was
all kinds of ways so the effective tax
rate is really what you need to look at
not the
actual marginal marginal rate my point
is
what makes sense is to structure the tax
structure so it brings in the most
revenue
that's not necessarily by raising rates
it's there's no static analysis you have
to do dynamic analysis they make a
a really really weak effort to do
dynamic analysis when they change tax
rates
you got people like aoc who's an expert
at two years ago she was an expert at
making bar
drinks as a bartender and now she's
she's she's an economist
it's insane that she thinks she knows oh
we need to do this we need to do that
how could she know any of this i mean
she's been there 20 minutes
what does she run i mean she was a she
was making you know what i wondered
during that time
what i wonder is how many companies were
founded during that time
i i would love to sit down i mean
started you know what
you know what ladies note make a note
let's bring on arthur laffer
on that would be great it's been about
four years since we had a month
let's bring arthur laffer on do you want
to join
so why don't we do and see if we can do
a group of four so it's the four of us
with laffer
let's get him out here i don't know if
he's traveling or not he's in nashville
tennessee if not maybe we'll call him up
maybe we'll call him up and we'll do a
call-in with him
with uh arthur laffer yeah i think 80s
again we went into the 80s in 1980 with
a 70
marginal rate plus whatever the
california minnesota new york crazy
state taxes were
crazy high taxes horrible economy we
came out of the 80s with a 28
tax rate okay and the economy was
booming and it boomed all the way
through the 90s
clinton raised taxes okay because he
could get away with it
not because not raising taxes wasn't
what helped the economy in the 1980s
in the 1990s it was the fact that we
lowered the taxes
and companies just started investing say
my god i get to keep
72 cents of every dollar i'm gonna i'm
gonna put my money back in my companies
i mean that made a lot of sense
you have no idea how much this is uh
kai this is the next how-to we're gonna
do we're gonna take a deep
dive on taxes history of taxes i want
every single article ever written on
this
i want to read every single article
written on this period i don't care if
it takes me 50 hours
anything that we pull up put a stack of
articles historically what happened with
it let's go through every single one
have our research guys start working on
at asap
you didn't know that taxes were no i
knew it was 90 what i didn't know i
didn't know the timeline
i thought it was less than a decade i
didn't know it was three decades that
this thing went through i thought it was
a
decade that it went through because of
world war ii and you know world war and
we're trying to collapse
i totally get the part that they had it
but i didn't know what the timeline was
i thought it was less than a decade
three decades
yeah that's what's crazy what were the
results
what were the results of having it that
way i mean what did it do because
well there's no way to know unless you
have two petri dishes of not doing it
that way and doing it that way i mean
unless you have two people
two two separate economies that are
identical what's the incentive though
what
what incentivizes somebody to really
work their tails off to build something
you take away a lot of the incentive
when the taxes are that high
but so so what they did was they said
look you don't if you if you want that's
innovation like well if you invest in
this then you don't have to pay it so
rather than pay it you say
if i don't if i make this dollar and i
don't do anything
i don't believe that 90 is a 90 that you
you you think it is i think the viewer
thinks it's like you make a hundred
grand you pay ninety thousand
if you don't do anything if you don't do
anything you know one write-offs that
they probably had at the time so that 91
was probably like a 40 percent tax well
this is probably why the effective
tax rate is was lower again with
individuals even companies my point is
that if you say if you make a million
dollars and you keep it
you're going to pay 900 000 in tax if or
on the next million dollars the nth
million dollars
if you if you take that that million
dollars and you invest and you buy
another printing press
then you can deduct it so you don't have
to pay so basically deductions were
worth a lot more nowadays oh it's
deductible what do you mean deductible
yeah
because i saved 30 40 cents on a dollar
no you still cost money
in the old days if something was
deducted to go to corporate tax rate
history of corporate tax rate and then
go to history capital gains tax rate
go to history corporate tax rate same
exact thing you did do corporate and
let's do
yeah go ahead and pull it up yeah go
perfect so let's take a look at this go
years does it show you yours or no well
i actually actually looked at this
yesterday and in the 40s 50s 60s look at
that ten percent
nothing what do you mean corporate taxes
were 10 and in the 30s 40 30s and then
after world war ii the game changed and
it went up to as much as 50
and then it goes with the high we've
been the highest in the world for a long
time we have the high score protection
and yet
it doesn't bring in that much money now
go to capital gains history of capital
gains taxes
taxes capital gains
go ahead click on that let's see what
comes out can i just make a point go
while you're doing this this is
this is sort of look go back and see if
you can find people are saying it's a
socialism and biden and bernie
but people don't understand the history
of taxes it's been way higher than it is
how much is too high i mean one percent
is too high but
it's just too much what's what's the
number that above above which it's
unreasonable well i mean
what's the state tax in illinois five
percent okay
what's the state tax in florida and
texas i've never paid six of my life
i've only lived in florida
so for me one percent state tax is too
high
for you five percent is fine because
you'll stay there i'm talking about
federal income tax
okay how much is too high whatever your
marginal tax bracket is what are your
favorite i mean i don't know what the
number is 50
too high look everyone wants to keep
their money
but how much is too much i don't know
how much is reasonable how much should
the rich pay interesting
i don't know 70 too high
you're not going to say 70 percent's too
high yes it is too high 60
too high but that's go goes back to my
point is everyone wants to harp on
taxes these days as if it's it's just
something that just appeared
because of socialist bernie sanders or
because of obama
this was something that was going on for
i don't know three to four freaking
decades i
i i i don't know the only question i got
is the following
you know uh uh you see a parent who's
like
where'd you to go who's that where are
you going what are you doing like
overly hovering over the kids girl turns
18 years old it's 48 guys
like dude screw you i'm dating the
tattoo guy with you know tattoos on his
forehead and
drinks ecstasy partying you can't say
[ __ ] and i'm living with them and i'm
moving out with them
say something right okay so we don't
understand that for two decades
right the consequence of being
overbearing parent right
we also don't understand the the
consequence of
taking away incentives for innovation
and entrepreneurship
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]
you